[Music]
reinvention to me means taking all the
knowledge that we've gathered in the
past and applying it to one single focal
point which is battling cancer
[Music]
my father was an entrepreneur and I've
always wanted to do something in
business but my innate passion was
rooted in the life sciences I played
around with insects the gardens and a
lot of science fairs and then
unfortunately my father passed away from
pancreatic cancer within a six-month
timeframe so after witnessing that it
certainly shaped my career into being
more focused to battling oncology and
cancer patients
initially I was always less confident
because I thought people would view me
as a younger kid but then once I
realized that hey it's really ultimately
about what you know so in the end you
know I worked harder I worked extra hard
and I was making sure I approached the
right advisors who advised me along the
way and it's just a combination that
enabled me to speak with confidence to
people normally there are twenty thirty
years senior to me
[Music]
the most challenging thing I think is
assembling a very top-notch world-class
team so I spend most of my time looking
for the best talents they'll you know
join us in this journey in fighting
cancer drug development is so complex
there's so many players involved there's
manufacturing clinical preclinical
development regulatory affairs legal
finance and accounting there's just no
way that one person can do it all so
what I do every day is to think of what
is the most important thing I could do
today and I try to prioritize my date
around that and I gather my team and
build my team around my weaknesses so
it's really amazing and recognizing what
I don't know and really just embracing
that it was initially challenging at
first to admit that I don't know
everything especially I need to
overcompensate for being young so
through that I was able to build the
best people and best team to help me and
the team to accomplish that vision
[Music]
you